Hollywood game night this is your show
it's a great show you one of the things
that you guys do on that show we do not
do that here is you encourage a lot of
drinking we on this I don't know we
encourage a lot of drinking but some
people take it you know they do offer it
we offer the drinks and I think it adds
to the party atmosphere and I think
that's what keeps it so loose and so fun
but we've had to cut people off we've
had to and I can you've had it you've
had you've had to get off celebrity
guests yeah have too much oh my god
slurring I mean our editors praise the
Lord are so wonderful but we've had some
really crazy situations with people who
are just slurring and falling all over
the place of being inappropriate okay
just ask you a question Kate tell us you
know I can't I can't I what if they have
like a problem yeah okay I'm asking you
because Andy's been the show it was it
was me and Billy Eichner and Mekhi
Phifer against three of the women from
Hot in Cleveland okay
- Betty White right and they got the an
immediately that they started pouring
booze down all of us yeah what's up -
you know right but no I I didn't I don't
think anybody got loopy I think you guys
were okay yeah they do it's one after
the other and I have to bed now - don't
you know if it's empty don't refill it
so do they do they have to tell people
like do the people it right
I wanna nother one oh you can well we
don't we can't say that cuz you can't
say no you can't do a celebrity
everybody knows that right sure I have
not found that to be true
I think you are very happy to me you'll
get these days you could be treated with
the respect and deference that you
deserve as a person on television water
down your drink yeah I have found that
people don't get funnier when they drink
now I don't think they get here they are
I've had guests come out here over the
years and I can smell the booze on them
and they suddenly think they're real
funny but instead all that's happening
is they're saying stuff slower stupider
and then they get to the punchline and
they wait a long time for a huge laugh
it's not
you